[Applause]
angry frustrated and desperate
protesters surround the president's
office in colombo
under the eyes of the police
sri lanka is facing its worst economic
crisis in decades
all saturday the protesters kept coming
most of them young people in what's
reported to be the biggest protest over
the crisis to date
public servants so we are here to say
that our voices needs to be heard and it
needs to be respected and this crisis
needs to end now because it has gone up
to the limit that where people cannot
bear anymore the crowds came from all of
sri lanka's diverse communities
this poster reads give our stolen money
back
and this says corrupt rulers are playing
with our future
in recent weeks the price of essential
goods rocketed and cooking gas and fuel
became
scarce power cuts last up to 13 hours
economists say a massive drop in tourism
revenue due to the easter bombing of
2019 and the pandemic coupled with a
loss of government revenue due to a
major pre-election tax cut far to blame
now there's not enough foreign currency
for the government to buy essentials
that's only one way out of this crisis
the rajapaksas has to be removed from
the positions and then only we can see
some sort of credible political
stability in the country and political
with the political stability only the
economic
sustainability will come into the
country the government is requesting a
bailout from the international monetary
fund and also seeking financial
assistance from india china and other
friendly countries
the government has described
demonstrators as extremists accusing
them of being politically manipulated
while a very few may fit this
description a vast majority of the
thousands of protesters have turned up
voluntarily
they say they want their futures back
and gotham rajapaksa and the government
must go
fernandez al jazeera colombo